euro Max highlights and here's your host
car instead hi there and a warm welcome
to another euro Max highlights coming to
you straight from Brandenburg Gate in
Berlin and let's kick off the show with
a look at the topics prehistoric
paintings featuring a replica of cave
artworks in southern France feathered
friends fly like a bird with a Swiss
built simulator and luxury living a new
exhibition opens at Victoria & Albert
Museum in one all France is certainly
blessed with a wealth of natural and
historic sites not to mention some
pretty incredible food and the Chauvet
Cave with its prehistoric paintings is
just one of their many riches it's
located in the AL - region in the South
of France and just last year it was
added to UNESCO list of world heritage
sites now until now anyone wishing to
actually see the artwork in the cave
would have been sorely disappointed as
it was of course inaccessible to the
public but now after years of
painstaking work it's been spectacularly
replicated and that to the very last
detail and we were among the first to
visit the new site
the cave lionesses on the hunt and their
wounded prey it's a world for more than
thirty thousand years ago with
rhinoceros bison wild horses captured on
the walls of the Chauvet Cave access to
the cave and the South of France is
restricted to researchers but now the
paintings have been faithfully
reproduced in an artificial cave that
will be accessible to all
see I clean up it's incredible how
realistic it all looks like in a real
cave you can dive into the past and
understand a bit about how people lived
back then it off isn't it I thickened
chemo it's even humid like in a real
cave you need the artificial cave cost
55 million euros to construct it's all
meant to be as accurate as possible even
the smell right from the start the
planning at the active participation of
experts familiar with the real cave such
as archaeologist Barnaby Morris it's the
largest reproduction ever and everything
you can see here the paintings the bones
have all been copied exactly so in a way
we're here in the original cave the name
is different however is called the
cavern of pont d'arc named after a
bridge in the region it's just two
kilometers from the original Chauvet
Cave in the southeastern ardèche state
bottom all the cave was discovered in
1994 by a group of three hikers and
named after the leader of the group
jean-marie Chauvet the entrance had been
blocked off for some 20,000 years by
fallen rocks that helped preserve the
more than 450 paintings of animals
inside considered some of the oldest
works of art in the world the find was a
sensation for scientists to protect the
precious paintings the cave was
immediately closed to the public today
we know that having lots of visitors
alters the climate in the cave it
promotes the growth of calcite sand mold
and they destroy the paintings at 3,000
square meters the replica is less than
half the size of the Chauvet Cave but it
contains all the important paintings the
present-day artists used the same
techniques as their prehistoric
predecessors Flintstone charcoal and
engravings
for Michelle claim all who oversaw
construction it was the biggest
challenge of his life medicina we
basically had our doubts the whole time
like when we put the first sculptures in
the hall and they seemed so lost in this
big building only when the cavern
replica took shape did we start to feel
that we would manage it that it would
work on the idea they did manage it a
few visitors have been able to have a
first look including a couple who run an
inn not far from the site I think it
will be a good alternative for tourists
the ardèche is mostly known for canoeing
and now there's finally a cultural
highlight that's very significant
for just 13 euros per person everyone
can now journey back to the Stone Age
well arguably since the Stone Age people
have dreamed of soaring through the air
like a bird and thanks to years of
technological developments we have
managed to come pretty close for things
like airplanes and paragliders and even
wingsuits for those real kamikazes but
the birds still always managed to do it
better which is why researchers in
Switzerland have tried to copy their
technique by creating a simulator that
gives you the illusion of flying in the
air like a bird now our reporter axel
prima visi tested it out to see if it
comes close or a little bit close even
to the real deal flying free as a bird
elegantly through the air and over the
landscape that's the ideal but somehow
it looks different with me the real
question is whether the illusion works
I am visiting the burglar Center near
Zurich in Switzerland Kevin Heller the
head of the center came up with the idea
for a bird flight simulator why are you
so fascinated by the fly of the birds
this generator sphere cone doesn't he we
humans can do it birds can move in
extremely complex ways they can land on
a dime which no airplane can manage they
can lift off very fast and they can
maneuver among the branches and we as
humans have no chance of doing anything
like what a bird can do gods are
breeding here at the moment from little
huts
you can watch the birds without
disturbing them the birth center
attracts 12,000 visitors a year and
Stefan Ella wanted to offer them more
than just observation huts and an
exhibition he wanted a flight simulator
but one that simulates bird flight not
an airplane max Reiner made the
simulation possible he and two
colleagues at the Zurich University of
the Arts developed what they call
thirdly this platform gives you the
feeling that you're really in the air in
navigating Max's team work for half a
year developing Berkeley he shows me
where you have to press the biggest
challenge for the team was getting the
mechanics to mesh smoothly with the
computer software the overall experience
is more intense when every aspect works
together when all your senses play along
and tell you that you're really aloft
and flying that's very different from
watching it on TV now you can put your
hands in here this is like your wings
now I'll give you a pair of 3d glasses
with the glasses you're really thrust
into the landscape
now you also get headphones so that you
really hear everything happening around
you Rick wish Alice Harris was indeed
thought up key
I'm flying over San Francisco we are
used to seeing cities from above almost
everyone has stood on top of a high-rise
and looked down so we have a better feel
for dimensions among buildings than in
nature that makes the virtual experience
more realistic and that's why the team
chose an urban backdrop for the bird
flight simulator I flipped my wings and
up I go I get used to maneuvering with
my wings quickly after a short time I
forget all about the real world a fan
simulates the width the interplay
between the virtual world in my goggles
and the real motion of the machine
produces a realistic illusion now you
have to rise up a bit go up go up go up
no that was too close you've crashed it
just really feels like flying and yeah
you really if you see a building you
just want to avoid yes avoid it and and
then just a keep keep flying and you get
addictive if you really want to do it
once more and more the bird flight
simulator is indeed addictive
during my second flight I felt a little
sick but the simulator is so much fun
I'm willing to accept that ok so now try
taking a look at your hands my wings
that's what makes me happy is that
people are content when they've finished
when they get out of the machine they're
all very happy I think that's remarkable
simply flying makes you happy sounds
fleeting
simply flying well
we humans will never be able to fly in
the air as smoothly as birds but a
flight with Burt Lee comes pretty close
and coming off of that what does luxury
mean to you perhaps things like leisure
time family a big house or a swimming
pool or even a dream holiday well it
seems that luxury can be many things to
many different people and we also can
assume that our perceptions of luxury
have changed dramatically compared to
those of our grandparents generation
well a brand new exhibition in London
tries to find some answers mechanical
clocks with every single detail crafted
by hand 2,500 hours to make a hat of
gold threads jewelry made of a thousand
hand knitted nylon bubbles an 18th
century crown studded with priceless
gems chandeliers made of LED lamps and
dandelions valuable exclusive and
opulent objects they take time and space
to make pure luxury but the Victoria and
Albert Museum in London wants to know
what is luxury we have chosen a question
and feel that it's necessary to start a
new debate again to start thinking about
luxury and to kind of open it up from
this course that we feel has been honed
in and has been very limited just
focusing on the luxury industry friends
etc worldwide luxury is often associated
with cost expensive clothes yachts big
villas and pricey cars are often high up
on people's wish lists
yet luxury means something different to
everyone it's something very personal
well being able to salvages and buy
whatever I like freedom I suppose not
sure his food luxury is like nice things
you know like things that you they just
add to life you know no need of it like
I can have all the things that are
important for me for example that my
family is healthy
with all the stress we have the day long
you know just time this is the biggest
luxury in Western industrialized
countries luxury often means having time
to enjoy a stroll or spending time with
friends a luxurious lifestyle also
includes rest and relaxation good health
and nutrition and being globally
connected Jonathon fares researches
luxury at the University of Southampton
and is the publisher of the journal
luxury which takes a critical look at
the subject the term luxury changes
constantly what's rare is considered
precious the nineteenth century the idea
of indoor private sanitation at one
point was an extreme luxury whereas now
in the West it is a social necessity
it's you know it's a legal requirement
and so we understand chronologically
that luxury has its own kind of
timescales but where those timescales
are being experienced I think halters so
in the West it moves quite rapidly in
other countries obviously the the
processes of something emerging as a
luxury is much much slower so things we
need to live to survive like clean air
are to this day luxury goods in some
emerging and developing countries as our
clean water education and food back to
the Victoria and Albert Museum
what is luxury the exhibition dares to
take a glimpse into the future
a DNA vending machine
halation warns about the loss of privacy
which could become a luxury good
rare-earths will get more expensive
natural resources are drying up plastic
furniture could become a luxury good
because oil is needed to produce plastic
the definition luxury will be influenced
by changes in society and I think that
the moment we are in there in a moment
where it's a universally applied turn so
much so that it is beginning to be
emptied out of its meaning having said
that I am NOT saying that it will
disappear completely and I think it
might well reimagine the future and have
quite a different meaning whether that's
as I say something to do with perhaps
abstinent something to do with less
having time for yourself the luxury of
the future these items reflect that
utopia a pen without ink a compass
without a needle and a watch without
hands the overwhelming impression for
years now at computer games trade fairs
is that the graphics just keep getting
more and more realistic but just as
there are fans of vintage fashions while
there are also fans of retro computer
games now these guys prefer the
old-style games from the days of pac-man
and Super Mario they have chat
communities all over the world and even
magazines devoted entirely to the retro
thing and now there are even some modern
games that have a retro style interface
and so we met up with two such
developers right here in Berlin at the
International games week retro games are
very much on vogue at this year's
international games week in Berlin
operating techniques are rudimentary and
the graphics are archaic but gamers here
put body and soul into them Berlin game
developers riad jimmy lee and johannes
chris mon love the 30 year old games
they're fascinated by pac-man and other
classics of the genre it's like old
furniture that you wouldn't ever put in
your living room nowadays because it's
cumbersome or weighs a ton but you still
admire it for the craftsmanship that
went
kunst do the hiding a closeness they
both recently gave up their jobs with a
major games developer to start their own
studio their first creation was the
curious Expedition a game of strategy
it's brand new but looks like a relic of
the 1990s the setting is the 1800s the
player heads an expedition off to
explore distant lands and overcome all
sorts of obstacles such as strange never
before contacted peoples or natural
disasters johannes Chrisman designs the
old-school graphics he conjures up
landscapes using just a handful of
pixels the game's simple no frills look
is another advantage our game won't be
outdated too quickly because it was
designed to be an antique we hope it'll
still be playable in five or ten years
time in contrast when the modern game
comes out today it already looks
outdated after six months plus there's a
reduction of the resolution which we
hope will leave more to the players
imagination desta fund as he disappeard
us all on one mia home became a bit the
game's concept is also influenced by the
classics as in the original adventure
games the player has to read a lot and
carry out complicated tasks if your
character dies you have to start all
over again with no saving your previous
progress riki game that can make you
tear your hair out for a few hours
that too is reminiscent of the old
difficult games there's a great
fascination with a game that's hard to
master and in which you can fail there
are lots of ways to lose and that's a
big attraction it's retro that's what
people usually call games that are more
than twenty years old this is the mother
of all commercial computer games pong
from the year 1972 a little later space
invaders came out it paved the way for a
series of others shoot-'em-up games
mario appeared in 1983 and made jump and
run games popular around
world then came the first graphic
adventure games Monkey Island from 1990
boasted outstanding graphics and a cult
following today more and more developers
are out to return to the old look as in
minecraft from 2009 with 56 million
copies sold it's one of the most
successful games in the world despite or
maybe precisely because of its graphics
gaming expert andreas Langa says those
images remind many people of their youth
these are fun computers these early
computer games became popular at the
time when computer technology as a whole
was spreading these graphics became
known along with the first personal
computers looking back today we know how
important this development was for us
digital revolution began back then and
so these retro graphics don't stand just
for dumb old games but for computer
technologies oh and retro games are
popping up in art too 8-bit graphics on
canvas here at Berlin games a week the
Game Boy is obviously still a huge
favorite and among the eye catchers at
the exhibition as is the Nintendo family
of figures the past inspiring the
present generation for the future
if a picture of us would hang here
someday what a fantastic idea that is
for now they just hope their game is a
hit and that someday people will look
back on it as a classic - well spring
has finally made its entrance here in
Germany and this year it had a bit of a
double whammy character to it and that's
because the federal garden show recently
opened its doors to the public will also
known as the Booga it takes place every
two years and it's always staged in a
different part of Germany well the idea
is of course to lure as many tourists as
possible with beautiful floral displays
and we headed out of the German capital
to find out how it's looking this year
the 2015 national garden show is a sea
of flowers this year the show is hosted
by the Havel region West of Berlin
the region is a jewel of natural beauty
with its River Way and scenic landscapes
for now through October visitors can
explore dozens of horticultural delights
all five host locations are located on
or close to the blue ribbon as the river
is being marketed oh great thing is that
we didn't have to develop any new sites
for the show we didn't go out into the
fields we went to places where people
actually live these are places that have
always had potential we've now
reinvented those sites around these
historical backdrops norm I noticed at
the time the event showcases the latest
trends in over 30 gardens many of them
highlight one of the themes of the show
water the gardens range from classic to
the less conventional some incorporating
objects found in the Havel River the
native flora of the Havel region is also
celebrated
among the other themes Gardens in
confined spaces
and it's motsi I and I can create
something from materials and works of
art I don't need acres of green space to
create an attractive garden even gotten
Zeus - we then drive 30 kilometers from
the town of Brandenburg - rotten oh that
trip makes us appreciate just how huge
an area this year's garden show covers
the Hubble River also runs through
rotten oh there's another blue ribbon
here for visitors to explore an art
installation
awesome boy filled us the Blue Ribbon is
a symbol for the hassle it will stretch
from Brandenburg to rotten oh and half
of it there will be lots to see for the
rest of the year until October and
that's very appealing Heights forth
there's something for everyone highlight
the trick now continues from Raqqa no to
the next destination of huddled back
about a 45 kilometer drive the highlight
here is the town's Church but it was a
challenge to maintain the theme budding
blooms and the scent of spring in such a
dimly lit space around 800 to a thousand
Lux of light here in the hall and we'll
be carrying the watering can through the
rows of plants here very carefully
because the floor is historical its
heartwood in hearthstone you have to be
pretty careful not to damage the floor
an importance to OCD this show is also
something special for visitors Virginia
reached no it's really impressive to see
so many plants in a church I really
enjoyed it a lot or Chandra chud limo
wasn't explained here just to take an
idea or two home with us we have season
tickets and we plan to use them often
the show runs until the end of October
so visitors can take in millions of
flowers in a sea of blossoms at
Germany's national garden show and that
does bring us to the end of this edition
of our euro max highlights we hope
you've enjoyed it and until we meet
again all the best from us here in
Berlin
just ciao and bye-bye
you